so what a season and what a finale how
does it feel to finally be able to talk
about this terrifying character you
brought to life
it feels like i've
been waiting for a year and a half to
talk about this if not two years so um
it it's it's it's like a sort of
treasure chest of madness has been
unleashed so it's uh
both incredibly gratifying and
terrifying in equal measure
so what do you think the fan's reaction
will be towards the volume 2 finale and
how can you describe it in one word
oh
goodness
um
i can't the answer to that question is
that i can't describe it in one word
there are too many words
um
if i'm to use uh
a saying that some people have been
hitting me up with on twitter it would
be you need to pay for my therapy
i agree becnus scared the living
me so
talk with fans and stuff what's the
craziest fan theory you've heard about
that now like for example people think
becna has been around since season one
episode one
well
i'll i'll leave whatever's out there out
there at the moment i think what i
really enjoyed um before
everyone kind of knew um and had
experienced volume one particularly uh
was the theories about who vetner could
be
um there was you know obviously a lot of
people gravitated towards billy um which
makes perfect sense some people said
brenner some people even said uh will
buy us himself um so that was always
interesting for me just from an outside
perspective looking at people digging
around but i'll leave i'll leave the
snooping to the snoopers
sounds good and then we know we took a
lot of inspiration from horizon but i'm
seeing a lot of freddy krueger and becca
were you able to able to get any advice
from robert england on playing this
horror character
do you know what's tragic is that i
never had the opportunity to meet robert
um unfortunately i kept asking when uh
he would come in and and we we were just
passing ships in the night which was
which was really unfortunate um but i
know matt and ross you know are huge
fans of of that of freddie and of that
franchise so um
you know i obviously there is some
inspiration drawn on that but like you
say for me personally hell raiser was
something that i really gravitated
towards and doug bradley has pinhead
particularly
so okay last question obviously everyone
wants to know will you be involved in
season five
my lips are sealed my my yeah my lips
are sealed you'll have to hold your
breath and wait
i'll be holding my breath we can't wait
it's so good so thank you so much for
your time and have a great day you're so
welcome thank you so much kiara
appreciate you thank you bye
you